okay now before you actually put any pen
to paper underneath there's some pity
what is Pythagoras's theorem pythons you
see if I gave you a right angle triangle
because that's what we're looking at
today that's a terrible dining-room
window okay what does that your system
tell us about the right angle triangle
any takers
okay the longest side which we give a
special name the hypotenuse okay what do
we do they'll have one use you see what
does it relate it relates to the
hypotenuse to the other two sides right
we tend to call them a and B right how
does it relate them what is the
relationship between the three sides of
a right angle triangle anyone want to
help me up we've been doing this for
years now what's the relationship
between the three sides of a right angle
triangle according to this old dead
Greek guy what's the relationship yeah
we're so close basically yeah okay thank
you it was very close okay so in case
you have it already you should draw that
little background underneath now in
words what does it mean in words sees
the longest side the hypotenuse so we
say that the square of the hypotenuse
the square of the hypotenuse okay it
equals to know how would you explain
what the right hand side is that's the
left hand side how would you work the
right hand side
okay now hold on I've got this this form
written down talking about the other
form in a second right so everything's
squared I do square root sounds anyway
yet okay so I think what I've gotten my
intern it's a Sun it's a Sun it goes to
the sum of what is it the sum of its the
squares of the two shorter sides isn't
it sum of the squares of the two shorter
sides you could just as easily have said
the two other sides because the shorter
sides have to be the other side there's
the hypotenuse it's the longest now
sometimes you will see this occasionally
right which is taking the square root of
both sides okay and then ignoring the
negative value okay now that's a
necessary result if you you know we
usually don't want to square the happen
is we want the hypotenuse okay and you
can see where it comes from
okay now I'm gonna recommend that you
come back to this I think this is what
you should write to begin with and not
this in the same way if you wanted to
find one of these other two sides right
if you do want the hypotenuse is the
subject I think rather than writing this
for instance a squared okay both of
these lines both of these results come
from Pythagoras theorem but then not
Pythagoras's theorem okay so if you can
distinguish between those two these are
kinds of like conclusions that you draw
or something but they're not up there
itself
okay so I reckon this is sort of the
line you should always start with okay
now Pythagoras theorem let's just really
really quickly use it for an example
okay how can we go ahead and find the
hypotenuse what should be the very first
thing that we write
maybe I should give us a name baby oh
good perfect okay
now by the way you know in geometry a
lot we try and emphasize me explain
justify why you saved you from my price
by a reason okay so generally if you say
whew Pythagoras theorem that should be
sufficient okay
a straighteners tell us where
prostitution five bits so we can
actually do this we don't need to take
that do we hundred forty four twenty
five so what's H 13 isn't it in fact
some of you might recognize five twelve
thirteen those three numbers we give
them a name I'm three four five and six
eight ten what do we call those yeah
that's right it comes from comes from
this guy's name again right so I should
write down H equals 13 and five twelve
thirteen is what we call a Pythagorean
triad and these these triple sets of
numbers isn't even a senator there's an
interesting thing in itself it's great
there's a really simple now before we
move off Pythagoras's theorem okay I
want to talk about the converse now
apart from being a good luck your shoe
brand what does it mean for something to
happen converse what is the Commerce or
something actually that's pressure I
wouldn't ask you to say it but who
reckons in their head they have an idea
of what a converse ears ends up anyone
any takers I'm just thinking of shoes
okay fine all right let me write
directly you have one okay so opposite
opposite I think is a very helpful word
it is different okay but I'm gonna go
after it
because I think it's helpful right have
a look at this this is Pythagoras
theorem in words
now the opposite of that is to kind of
turn it around do it in reverse
okay I should have probably said wipe
the beginning right in right triangles
as in triangles with the right angles
okay
so fun to turn this around okay I'm
going to say if now is that a dual this
okay if C squared equals a squared plus
B squared in a triangle okay if that
happens to be true then the triangle is
right angle so you can see that opposite
is on the right track I think it's not
quite the opposite that's why we have
these two English words converse and
opposite but he's taking that idea and
therefore being around okay that's what
we mean by the converse
okay now Pythagoras theorem is true the
converse of Pythagoras theorem is also
true the reason why I'm making a big
deal about it is it's not always the
case
okay give me an example if you have a
square don't write this down I'm just
trying to get the idea across right if
you have a square all the angles are not
there all they call you can tell me more
than that what are they all equal to
because the quadrilateral 360 they're
all equal to 90
okay 90 degrees okay so that's a true
statement okay but the converse of this
statement is not true right think about
it if I turn it around what would happen
if I turned it around if all the angles
you know four-sided figure 90 degrees
it's not necessarily a square is it what
else could be it could be rectangle
right so the fact that Pythagoras
theorem is true and the converse is true
is actually kind of a big deal it's
important to us okay
so how do you use this in example a G
okay don't give you a triangle right you
go something like this
and they'll give you numbers like that
should work okay
and they'll say is this triangle widened
or not okay how are we gonna do it
which one is a which ones be in which
ones see okay doesn't matter which one a
and B are cuz we're gonna square them
and add them up anyway but C's important
sees the important one right it's gonna
be on one side so let's call this one a
and call this one B okay yeah let me
tell you first what not to do we get
another color to integrate it here's
what some people will do they'll say I
know what this looks like this is about
writing with triangles and it's about
Pythagoras so they'll write down
Pythagoras theorem with these numbers
don't go okay ace sorry a squared a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
and then we'll calculate 6925 for 16 of
course is 41 life subject and they say
oh hold on
41 is not equal to 49 and then they'll
say okay therefore is a right angle or
not it's not because it doesn't fit the
relationship right
okay now and tell me what's the problem
with this way of saying you know even
though I got the right answer at the end
why why did I say this why did I why
don't I get to here and then change an
equal sign into a not equal sign like
seriously remember 30 seconds ago what
was the bullet Francisco into my brain
okay it was here I don't know he I don't
know I know I know okay so that's why I
say it's not equals but all of these are
the same guy right surely if this one
this line isn't equal then none of them
are equal right
please tell me that's that's true right
okay so therefore therefore please
please please do not start with this
line okay it's it's it's the whole thing
is bogus
okay because you started off assuming
something which is wrong from the
beginning okay
instead let's take each of these two
suicides and we're working about them
separately okay the numbers are going to
be the same you draw the same conclusion
at the end but you're not going to be
lying to yourself okay so let me just
rehearse that for you this is the way
I'd like you to send them out okay so
you can follow along with me a squared
plus B squared that's still going to be
five squared plus four squared
still 25 and 16 still 41 okay C squared
still seven squared still so now this
point I can conclude haha the sum of
those two squares is not equal to the
square root of the last one okay how can
you see all the numbers all the maths of
it it all works out the same okay but
the way you present it totally different
okay it makes a real difference